[Musique]
c'est la première fois qu'il se voit en
vraie pointure bien toi
entre les deux compétiteurs
62 ans d'écart mais si les changes
semblent cordiale fait mon
arrière-arrière-petit-fils on a perdu ne
vous fiez pas aux apparences
quand on les a rencontrés en début
d'année tout semblait séparer roger 85
ans de nicolas 23 le premier en touraine
et ancien champion d'europe de
bodybuilding
avec des méthodes de travail
très particulière
le second dans la sarthe est footballeur
amateur très présent sur les réseaux
sociaux avec une formation de coach
sportif entre eux tout se corse pour une
histoire de records en 2017 roger entre
au guinness book avec
6788 contraction abdominale en une heure
le problème c'est que nicolas prétend
l'avoir largement dépassé à l'époque la
pilule est dure à avaler pour roger mais
pas en tant que fier d'hygiène vous a
battu de négatif ça n'existe pas j'ai
reçu aucune félicitation lui je pensais
qu'il être plus fair play que ça d'abord
j'avais pas le fait du site est il
l'aurait battue dans les bonnes
conditions oui il dit j'ai pas un record
parce que j'ai pas respecter certains
critères
alors pour régler ce différend il décide
de s'affronter en duel le week-end
dernier
cette fois pour comptabiliser les
mouvements il y a deux huissiers il
s'agit d'un concours de crunch qui est
une petit particulier d'abdos fois mais
là encore il y a des désaccords donc tu
descends tu le bas date et rôle des
matches comme ça vous pouvez non mais
c'est c'est pas bon ça donc à l'arrêt
ressaisir de là tu peux en faire dix
mille situe à cette vidéo aisée pour les
noms que je monte tous les eaux
naturelles pas tous les os je monte pas
mais je décolle
et c'est enfin parti pour une heure
d'effort il faut bien un minimum de
mouvements des pôles pour que huissier
valide la contraction abdominale sinon
rappel à l'ordre
les victimes quand la salle se réveille
elle se divise en deux
il ya la team roger en son temps mais
c'est pas plus mal parce que votre avis
t on lors de ce qu'a fait la gauche
risque de se fatiguer
et la team ico qui fait un cas à la 51e
minute de ce duel
il a battu un record déjà
donc on est bien content maintenant
c'est que du bonus pour roger dernière
seconde pour revenir au score bientôt
l'heure du verdict pour connaître le
seigneur des abdos
8004 pour nico
6745 pour l'octogénaire des bizarrement
plus fait qu'il y ait des deux n'est pas
celui qu'on croit il est mal là nicolas
- moi je suis aidé mes gants j'ai oublié
mes gants que jamais le crâne jeté une
savonnette mon corps
le nouveau roman
les anciens ils ont peut-être
l'expérience mais nous les jeunes on a
faim et quand on a faim on est
inarrêtable et d'où vient de la ville
d'oujda chez nous on dirait on a la
dalle les records c'est fait pour une
voiture pas de secret bon perdant roger
garde malgré tout leur corps et plus de
60 ans
[Applaudissements]